every now and again
our public leaders say things that
they're not supposed to say they say the
quiet part out loud as i referenced
yesterday with that movie wizard of oz
and the munchkins and i'm not going to
get into that whole munchkin orgy thing
again because i'm sure many of you left
and then an hour of your life was sucked
away uh but
nancy pelosi uh just sort of slipped
this is just a very subtle slip in what
she's saying here well you listen
keep government open we intend we have
to do those imminently uh
more intimately even uh to address the
full
obama agenda of building back better
with and i love to say building that
better
nancy
nancy you just said the quiet part out
loud you do know that joe biden is the
guy that we're supposed to think is
president and in charge of everything
allow me to quote her
keep government open to address the full
obama agenda of building back better
she meant biden but she said obama and
you know often this is now coming up all
the time because anyone with half a
brain realizes that biden is not in
charge right he's just not he's the
figurehead that they put out there to
read often poorly off the teleprompter
and mumble and stumble through anything
that he's doing but you are now seeing
what this really is about and this is
about
obama basically getting a third term
it's obama's agenda of building back
better it's strange i remember those
eight years when obama was president did
he ever say building back better i don't
think so but he did once say i'm sure
many of you have seen the interview
where he said he would love to have a
third term he knows he can't have a
third term so he'd love to just pull the
strings from behind so every now and
again they tell you exactly what they're
doing so if you wonder where this
radical
crazy leftist progressive ever expanding
state 4 3.5 trillion dollars equals zero
more and more climate shutdowns and
masks and lockdowns and mandates and
everyone will be backs and now we just
saw this morning
i just saw it before we started uh that
the administration is going to start
punishing companies that don't make sure
that all of their employees are
vaccinated we'll see if they start with
you know
companies at 100 people or 50 people or
a thousand people who knows what they're
going to do
but you know that that'll keep moving
once they get it to 100 people they'll
get it to 50 people and 25 people and 10
people and they literally won't let you
work alone if you work alone remotely in
your basement they will come for you too
so this has something to do with barack
obama and his third term i don't think
that is a conspiracy theory nancy pelosi
said it right there obama's build back
better and obama himself said he wanted
a third term
these people are gross